on
bonjour est ravie de vous retrouver à
bruxelles au parlement européen pour
cette nouvelle saison de roberto
dans cette émission direction la grèce
où la crise économique est en train de
virer à la crise sanitaire les grecs
n'ont plus les moyens de se soigner les
hôpitaux n'ont plus de médicaments nous
serons avec médecins du monde qui vient
d'ouvrir là bas un dispensaire
l'actualité c'est aussi le pacte
budgétaire européen qui suscite la
cacophonie en france mais peut-on
vraiment s'en passer c'est la question
de la semaine 2 mars 2012 sommet de
bruxelles 25 pays s'engagent à réduire
leur dette et ramener leurs comptes à
l'équilibré
parmi les signataires du traité
l'allemagne d'angela merkel et la france
de nicolas sarkozy
deux pays refusent le pacte la
grande-bretagne et la république tchèque
deux mois plus tard un pacte de
croissance est adopté à la demande du
nouveau président français comparé à
d'autres traités le texte est très court
24 pages ses articles et surtout une
fameuse règle d'or le déficit public
structurel ne doit pas dépasser 0,5 pour
cent de la richesse d'un pays autre
interdiction
la dette des pays signataires doit être
inférieur à 60% du produit intérieur
brut
et attention ceux qui violent les règles
seront passibles de sanctions infligées
par la cour européenne de justice
des pénalités pouvant atteindre 0,1 pour
cent du pib soit quelque deux milliards
d'euros pour la france
le traité est en cours de ratification
dans une dizaine de pays dont
l'allemagne la belgique les pays bas et
la france où le texte sera présenté à
l'assemblée le 2 octobre si tout le
monde accepte la nécessité de réduire la
dette certains économistes estiment que
ce traité adopté en période de crise
condamne les états à la rigueur une
potion amère mais peut-on vraiment se
passer du traité budgétaire
pour cette première émission de la
saison philippe lambert c'est avec nous
bonjour vous êtes député coprésident du
parti des verts et puis spécialistes ici
des questions économiques au parlement
européen alors ce traité budgétaire est
critiquée en france il suscite même une
véritable cacophonie chez les verts des
instances du parti chez nous ont rejeté
ce traité est ce que vous vous comprenez
cette cacophonie
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
cacophonie quand vous avez une décision
qui est prise par 70% d'une assemblée je
pense que c'est un vote très net est
donc là je pense que la cacophonie est
causée par certains déçus du vote des
verts je peux comprendre qu'ils soient
déçus mais il faut aussi respecter la
loi de la majorité la question vous
posiez c'est peut-on se passer de ce
traité la réponse est oui absolument
que fait ce traité ils répètent des
choses qui se trouve déjà dans le droit
européen et on peut se demander mais
pourquoi et bien parce que certains en
europe et en amérique et la première
n'ont pas confiance dans le droit
européen et dans la capacité de la
commission de faire respecter ce droit
par des états membres la seule
différence qu'il y a entre ce qui est
inscrit aujourd'hui vous savez c'est
tout le débat sur le six pack la
gouvernance économique européenne
ce qu'il y a dans le droit européen et
ce traité c'est un resserrement de la
norme de déficit structurel acceptable
d'un point de pib à 0,5 point de pib est
ce que ça change pour ben ça veut dire
que simplement on veut encore encadré
plus fort non pas les déficits publics
mais bien les dépenses publiques car le
problème de ce traité c'est qu'il est
déséquilibré c'est à dire que au lieu
il annonce qu'il veut réduire les
déficits mais en réalité le seul moyen
d'action qu'on les états membres c'est
couper dans les dépenses pourquoi parce
que sur le front des recettes des impôts
la loi qui joue n'est pas celle de la
coopération et de la discipline commune
c'est la loi de la compétition débridée
entre les états membres
et vous savez que la compétition fiscale
mène les recettes à descendre toujours
plus aujourd'hui la plupart des
multinationales européennes payent 2 ou
3 % d'impôt sur leurs bénéfices ce qui
est évidemment incompatible avec les
profits qu'elles font et ce qui veut
dire que donc on affaiblit les recettes
des états membres et on leur demande
d'équilibrer leur budget en périodes en
plus de ça où la crise s'approfondit et
donc où toutes les dépenses de sécurité
sociale par exemple augmentent
on voit bien sûr la cua s'amène pour
vous résumer en quelques mots
vous dites que ce traité c'est une
menace pour la croissance ont en tout
cas c'est une menace pour le bon
fonctionnement des économies européennes
si on va avoir une stratégie crédible de
remise en route et de réorientation de
l'économie européenne
mais c'est clair que ce traité est un
symbole très largement mais qui se
trouve en travers de ses troupes là
alors à la demande du nouveau président
français élu en mai dernier françois
hollande un pacte de croissance a été
adoptée à côté de ce traité budgétaire
est ce qu'il est suffisant pour cela
évidemment absolument rien à voir si je
peux me permettre de faire une
comparaison c'est comme si vous vous
engagez à faire un régime pour les 30 ou
40 ou 50 ans on ne sait pas au fait
puisque c'est illimité dans le temps qui
viennent
mais en contrepartie on vous permet
d'aller une fois au restaurant manger un
steak frites avant de commencer votre
régime à quoi est-ce que ça rime je veux
dire on ne peut pas mettre sur le même
pied un traité permanents et des
investissements ponctuels qui porte sur
tenez vous bien 0,5 pour cent du pib
européen autrement dit on va s'engager à
investir si tout va bien si tout va bien
un demi point de pib en 2012 2013 2014
en échange d'une discipline budgétaire
qui est excessive pour les 30 40 50 ans
qui viennent ça n'a évidemment on ne
peut pas mettre les deux choses en
rapport
ça veut dire que les zetas groupe pieds
et mains liés
perdront des marges de manoeuvre et vous
ça n'a pas réglé pour autant les
problèmes de non non non maintenant le
principe d'une monnaie partager le fait
qu'une monnaie partager exige une
discipline commune
aucune discussion là dessus mais tout
mais tout dispositif est en place dans
le cadre du droit européen ce traité
c'est une sucette que l'on donne à
angela merkel pour quelque part apaiser
l'opinion publique allemande
tout le monde et ça donne du mois
décembre quand on négocie et ce pacte et
que j'en discutais avec le président la
commission comme disait-il
et bien quand ils défient dans mon
bureau les 26 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement me dit ce traité on n'en
veut pas ça ne sert à rien tout et
défiant décision politique finalement au
fond c'est complètement c'est d'un
symbole que l'on veut donner pour apc
la chancelière allemande et le peuple
allemand désole le peuple allemand est
aussi motivée par des bars des
motivations où l'irrationnel à sa part
qui est dû à l'histoire allemande mais
je rassure l'allemagne eux il y a
également des préoccupations qui ne sont
pas de même nature dans d'autres états
européens et on peut pas faire l'europe
simplement en exécutant la volonté
fut-elle fut-elle acceptable du peuple
allemand désolé les allemands pour qui
j'ai beaucoup de respect sont 80
millions de citoyens européens ils ne
sont pas les 500 millions et donc on ne
peut pas faire à traiter exclusivement
pour complaire à une chancelière qui en
réalité a du mal à tenir tête à son
opinion publique
donc pour vous il manque un certain
contrôle démocratique où cette évidence
est évident aujourd'hui ça c'est c'est
celle-là grétry à adopter c'est parce
que je reviens du traité dans toute la
gouvernance économique européenne
on se trouve dans une situation
aujourd'hui où une commission européenne
prend des décisions de nature politique
en grèce au portugal etc
alors on peut dire elle est négocié avec
des gouvernements et du oui mais en
réalité tout le monde sait bien qu'elle
impose un certain nombre de choix sans
savoir comme le dit paul de grock état
libéral prof d'économie mais donc ancien
sénateur libéral en belgique il dit la
commission prend des décisions dont elle
n'a pas à payer le prix politique ça ne
va pas on ne peut pas confier des
décisions politiques à une instance qui
n'est pas comptable de ses actes
démocratiquement et ça c'est ce qu'on
doit mettre en place si on veut vraiment
faire accepter la gouvernance économique
européenne par des peuples à
daniel cohn bendit dj une chose un peu
différente votre position vous l'assumez
y dit aussi qu'ils que c'est quand même
un moyen de régler cette crise qui n'en
fait jamais la vraie c'est tout
simplement factuellement faux
aujourd'hui tout le dispositif que nous
avons mis en place au niveau de la
gouvernance économique européenne
perdons le droit européen permet de
faire tout ce que l'on veut en terme de
discipline budgétaire et je vous dis ce
traité est purement symbolique mais un
maillot avec des sanctions positionné
pour lui évidemment mais évidemment les
règles et je préfère quand même que des
sanctions soient prises par une
commission que par une cour de justice
européenne enfin on ne peut quand même
pas le gouvernement des juges ce serait
encore à l'affaiblissement sadran des
autres si ceux-ci ceci étant c'est clair
que le seul point sur lequel la cour de
justice peut vraiment attaquer les états
c'est sur la non traduction dans leur
droit national de la règle d'or est donc
elle ne peut pas ce n'est pas elle qui
va surveiller l'exécution de la règle
d'or c'est simplement la transposition
dans le droit national qui est soumise à
la rime et comme dans tout le droit
européen de la cour européenne de
justice mais de toute manière il y
aujourd'hui tout un dispositif avec les
sanctions à la clé pour assurer la
discipline budgétaire dans l'union
pourquoi bretons se traiter en plus
alors on a bien compris votre message va
passer à un autre sujet au menu de
l'actualité européenne les ogm puisqu'un
film une étude scientifique choc
viennent de sortir et font beaucoup
d'eau font couler beaucoup d'encre en
france regardez ce zapping et ses images
impressionnantes on en parle juste après
cette image a fait le tour du monde
un rat de laboratoire nourris aux ogm du
géant américain monsanto la tumeur
mammaire que cette femelle à développer
fait froid dans le dos pendant deux ans
des chercheurs français ont travaillé
dans le plus grand secret sur des rats
nourris au maïs transgénique traiter ou
non à l'herbicide roundup monsanto
l'entreprise qui développe ses maïs
explique qu'elle prendra en compte ces
résultats mais selon des centaines
d'autres études scientifiques ce maïs
est sans danger et la méthodologie de
l'étude en question est critiqué quels
produits peuvent contenir des ogm dans
les rayons de supermarchés le lait la
viande et les oeufs sont les plus
concernés ils le sont indirectement
quand les bêtes sont nourries par des
céréales ogm importés et dans ce cas là
il n'y a aucune obligation de l'indiquer
et voilà par le former sur ja qu'on
l'achète
voilà on achète ça s'en vient de rentrer
chez pas trop autres d'où on ne sait pas
trop d'où en fait le soja est composée
deuxième à 95%
il provient essentiellement d'argentine
du brésil cela fait des années que
c'était le bonheur de vaches laitières
nourrit son cheptel avec une question
d'efficacité
c'est un problème contre le génie
génétique on peut faire de l'insuline
avec du génie génétique
c'est un problème de prendre des champs
des agriculteurs pour une paillasse de
scientifiques et les assiettes de
consommateurs pour une période
industrielle et ça on peut pas accepter
si on ne fait pas de test voilà alors
cette étude en question et a été réalisé
par gilles eric séralini un scientifique
est connu pour être pour ses positions
contre les ogm elle a été publiée dans
une revue scientifique est ce que pour
vous il faut la prendre ce qu'il faut
prendre cette étude au sérieux le qu'il
ya urgence à agir
ce n'est pas moi qui dit qu'il faut la
prendre au sérieux ce sont tous les
scientifiques qui ont vérifié ce papier
avant qu'ils ne soient publiés dans une
revue scientifique
il ya tout un processus de contrôle de
la validité
des résultats on n'aurait pas pu publier
cette étude si des scientifiques
n'auraient pas dit ça nous semble au
sérieux donc s'il me le dise je ne suis
qu'un ingénieur je ne suis pas
scientifique et donc j'imagine que ça
doit être pris au sérieux mais d'autres
scientifiques disent non cette étude est
partial
seuls des petits échantillons ont été
testés
c'est un peu comme chercher des poux de
rethel et j'aimerais bien alors qu'on
avait privé j'aimerais bien que les
mêmes scientifiques disent ce qu'ils
pensent des études faites par monsanto
et d'autres qui porte sur des
échantillons encore plus faibles sur des
durées encore plus faibles et où les
effets combinés de l'eau gm et de
l'ennemi s'il ne sont pas neutres ne
sont pas mesurés donc je dis si cette
étude a déclaré un scientifique et bien
que nous les vérifions et que nous les
régressions s'il y en a mais je pense
que si cet été est considérée comme
ayant des 40 scientifiques
je pense que les études réalisées par
l'industrie des ogm sont encore plus
suspecte d'autant plus qu'à aller
franchement lorsque vous étiez étudiante
et que j'étais étudiant bien sûr on
aurait bien aimé s'évaluer nous mêmes
mais quelle crédibilité d'études
réalisées par ceux qui ont un intérêt à
ce que ces études donnent des résultats
positifs je dire en général on ne
demande pas aux étudiants de sévaz
lui-même quand on demande aux
industriels d'évaluer eux mêmes les
produits qu'ils mettent sur le marché or
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
alors en attendant les ogm la culture
des ogm est interdite en france en
italie puisqu'il ya eu un moratoire mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'ils ne se
retrouvent pas dans la même veine à
menton abondantes ont finalement des
nourritures allié à nîmes il ya des
craintes aujourd'hui le citoyen européen
mange peut-être des ogm sans le savoir
non pas peut-être il nous mangeons tous
ces ogm et donc nous le savons la
question c'est pouvons nous sortir de
cette de cette impasse autrement dit
aujourd'hui au lieu de laisser jouer la
logique du marché qui permettrait aux
consommateurs de choisir de dire par
exemple eh bien je souhaite acheter des
produits sans ogm
aujourd'hui l'industrie se bat pour que
par exemple nous n'étions pas les
produits nonne exempt de gm de manière
visible elle ne veut pas la transparence
elle ne veut pas la transparence des
études scientifiques de ses propres
études scientifiques
elle ne veut pas la transparence de
l'équité j'ai donc je me pose la
question
qu'at-elle à cacher est-elle à ce point
craintif du marché la réaction des
clients pour qu' elle ne veut elle
fouille les s'entretenir dans le doute
est donc aujourd'hui je suis désolé de
le dire mais les autres cures antiste on
nous fait souvent à nous le prouve
le procès vous savez les vs êtes content
le progrès est d offrir en dise
aujourd'hui ceux qui veulent les faits
la vérité des choses mesurables c'est
nous ceux qui veulent empêcher cela ce
sont les promoteurs des ogm ceux qui ont
du business à faire dans ce domaine là
et donc là je dis il faut peut-être
inverser la charge de la preuve
alors venez qu'il ya des raisons de ne
pas faire confiance aux industriels qui
refusent l'étiquetage est ce qu'on peut
faire confiance aux autorités
européennes de contrôle celles qui sont
chargés d'assurer cette transparence et
l'instant où ces autorités sont passé
moi l'expression cul et chemise avec
avec l'industrie l'industrie
agroalimentaire on a un véritable
problème les conflits d'intérêts entre
ceux qui font partie des panels
d'évaluation des produits au sein de
l'agencé européenne de sécurité
alimentaire et l'industrie sont légion
c'est la directrice même du dudu delage
ans qui a dû démissionner m de conflit
d'intérêts mais évidemment est donc là
la confiance a été ébranlée et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que la sagesse je
recommanderais que quelques états
membres commandite une réédition de
l'étude du professeur séralini pour
confirmer ou infirmer ces résultats de
manière à ce qu'on puisse avoir un point
de vue réellement indépendant à la fois
de l'industrie et d'une agence dont on
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui elle ne jouit
plus de la confiance des législateurs
ici dans cette maison
donc il faut revoir le système de
contrôle européen mais je crois en tout
cas qu'il faut mettre en place des
règles de
de gestion des conflits d'intérêts
extrêmement strictes de manière à éviter
que ceux qui sont dans les panels
d'évaluation n'est pour la moindre
raison partie liée avec l'industrie
c'est l'un ou l'autre vous devrez
choisir ou bien vous êtes un évaluateur
ou bien vous êtes salarié de l'industrie
mais vous ne pouvez pas faire les deux
on sait que les lobbys sont très
puissants on les voit ici au parlement
européen ce que vous pensez que le
rapport cette question des ogm il ya
aussi une influence des lobbys c'est ça
que vous versez dessus dessous les
choses qui n'est selon qu'ils ne sont
pas effrayés par les lobbys c'est clair
qu'il y à une activité de lobbying
intense qui se parlent et qui se passe
ici au parlement européen
mais la question c'est les députés
sont-ils assez solide pour résister à
cela c'est surtout c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser personnellement j'ai
tous les jours des banquiers dans dans
mon bureau
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils viennent me
vendre je disais que je vois le club
allemand comme comme comme l'évangile
est donc très franchement moi je n'ai
pas peur des lobbystes ce que je
constate le têt sais que certains
d'entre nous sont peut-être plus
réceptifs à son argument surtout quand
on leur dit faites attention ne régule
n'est pas parce que ça risque de tuer
l'économie européenne
c'est une sorte de lieu commun qu'on
entend tous les sujets je pense que les
industriels ne sont peut-être pas les
mieux placés pour nous dire ce qu'il
faut faire pour ainsi assurer l'avenir
de notre économie
merci beaucoup philippe lambert on vous
laisse repartir dans l'hémicycle mais
l'émission continue on se rend cette
semaine en grèce la grèce ou la crise
sanitaire succède à la crise économique
manque de médecins hôpitaux débordés
regardez cet état des lieux réalisé par
betty lachguer avec georges et à
beaucourt
athènes aujourd'hui la capitale est
aussi connue pour ses vestiges que pour
son économie ruinée par la crise
les grecs s'enfonce de plus en plus dans
la pauvreté
au point de renoncer à se soigner c'est
le cas de génie voilà ça c'est mon
palais génie à 63 ans elle est retraitée
depuis deux ans mais l'état ne lui a
toujours rien versé sans pension
impossible pour elle de payer son
assurance maladie tout ce qui les
intéresse ce sont des taxes en plus de
son cholestérol et de son asthme
eugénie a contracté une grippe h1n1 il y
a un an et demi depuis elle n'a pas vu
un seul médecin
aujourd'hui c'est une tumeur au ventre
qui l'inquiète on m'a donné un papier
pour aller enlever les tumeurs il y
avait écrit dessus sans ressources il
est urgent d'enlever la tumeur il m'a
envoyé balader c'était dans un hôpital
un ami lui conseille alors d'aller à la
polyclinique de médecins du monde pour
se faire soigner gratuitement tout va
beaucoup plus vite
elle obtient deux rendez vous en moins
d'une semaine
aujourd'hui elle s'y rend pour se faire
examiner ça fait mal ça ressemble à des
ganglions
pendant ce temps là le centre de soins
ne désemplit pas à l'origine seules des
migrants ou des demandeurs d'asile y
était reçue depuis trois ans la
cinquantaine de bénévoles a vu affluer
un nouveau public de grecs votre colonne
va bien pas de souci ces documents
viennent de l'hôpital moi je voulais un
avis neutre d'un médecin ici il voit
plus de gens qui viennent de tous les
coins du monde et surtout je viens parce
que j'ai conscience et si les athéniens
se détournent des hôpitaux publics
c'est aussi parce qu'il faut payer 5
euros de droit d'entrée et apporter ses
propres médicaments alors qu'ici tout
est gratuit
j'espère que les choses vont s'arranger
s'améliorer là j'ai l'impression qu'on
est au fond du trou que ça peut pas être
pire
aujourd'hui près de 50% des patients
sont grecs face à cette augmentation les
ong a donc dû s'adapter
les bénévoles ont arrêté leurs missions
à l'étranger pour pouvoir s'occuper des
grecs les plus démunis
cela fait déjà deux trois ans qu'un
grand nombre de personnes une grosse
vague ne peut pas subvenir à des besoins
essentiels et cela est dû à une hausse
du taux de chômage et au fait que de
plus en plus de personnes ne sont pas
assurés et ça c'est grave parce que ça
touche aussi leur enfant retour avec
eugénie au delà de la consultation
médicale elle est aussi venu chercher un
peu de réconfort une oreille attentive
avant moi je travaillais dans
l'entreprise de chocolat lyon lyon mais
ce sont mes chocolats préféré hamon
avait poc j'étais une vraie dame voulait
toujours il ne faut pas abuser c'est pas
l'argent qui fait de vous une vraie dame
temps de la consultation
eugénie attend maintenant son tour pour
récupérer ses médicaments
donc voila tu as compris comment ça se
passe ça c'est pour 5 millilitres donc
toi c'est cinq fois qu'il faut remplir
cette mission fait aujourd'hui partie du
quotidien delo ong
car faute d'approvisionnement les
pharmacies grecs n'ont tout simplement
plus de médicaments alors un médecin du
monde
la solidarité s'organise la plupart des
médicaments ce sont des dons de médecins
du monde
là c'est un médecin qui a changé la
prescription d'un patient et il n'a plus
besoin d'une boîte
donc il nous l'a rapporté les gens
récupèrent aussi les boîtes des amis ou
des proches
eugénie rentrer chez elle mais elle va
devoir revenir dans deux jours pour
passer des radiographies
je vais prendre un peu de ventoline sava
patron finalement même lorsqu'elle aura
une pension et une assurance maladie
eugénie ne compte pas retourner à
l'hôpital je veux avoir confiance en
allant dans un hôpital où on puisse
l'examiner de manière humaine
on n'est pas des animaux on a travaillé
pour cette étape pourri on a beaucoup
donné et on nous considère comme des
déchets cameron crowe périat comme jenny
30% de la population auraient déjà été
exclus du système de santé grec
et si l'état prévoit encore de nouvelles
coupes dans ce secteur la santé pourrait
bientôt devenir un privilège au lieu
d'un droit alors là donc pour ce
reportage à athènes nous avons été
rejoints par pierre vermeren bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
médecins du monde ici en belgique donc
la même ong que celle que nous allons
devoir dans le reportage est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il y a actuellement en
grèce une véritable crise sanitaire
je pense qu'on peut le dire dans le sens
où les budgets hospitaliers ont été
réduits de 40%
donc on ne sait pas continuer un système
de santé en tout cas au niveau
hospitalier avec de telles coupes
budgétaires donc mais je pense que les
l'impact et on le voit dans dans ce
reportage l'impact sur la population est
structurelle et donc on a des monsieur
madame tout le monde qui sont
directement impactés
parce que c'est ça la nouveauté en fait
avant c'était des personnes ont des
immigrés sans papiers etc
là ce sont des grecs maintenant on va
dire de la classe moyenne qui viennent
chez vous c'est à dire qu'on voit cela
ça c'est généralement le les systèmes de
santé mais les systèmes généraux de
sécurité sociale
cette tendance à exclure ceux qui se
trouvent à la marge dans la grande
précarité
ce qui vient de l'extérieur etc
aujourd'hui c'est le coeur même qui est
touchée alors c'est le coeur certes des
personnes qui sont les moins bien nantis
donc des personnes qui ont quitté des
travailleurs sans emploi des personnes
âgées des pensionnés et puis
progressivement
si les coupes continuent sa touche de
plus en plus la classe la classe moyenne
ce qui constitue un problème général que
ce soit sauf les classes moyennes ou sur
les personnes précarisées donc en grèce
oui on peut parler de crise sanitaire en
tout cas au niveau hospitalier au niveau
d'un médecine qu'il ya un deuxième
problème c'est celui de la confiance on
le voit très bien dans le reportage je
sais que le système sanitaire pose alors
un problème d'accès et les personnes
perdent confiance aussi et ça c'est
quand même quelque chose qui touche tout
le monde et auquel il faut être
extrêmement attentif parce que des
organisations comme médecins du monde
non pas du tout vocation à remplacer le
système c'est simplement ddd révélateur
de problèmes et donc il faut vraiment
veiller à ce que les systèmes de santé
garde la confiance de l'apocalypse parlé
de la confiance dans le système de santé
est-ce que ce qui est en train de se
passer actuellement en grèce c'est né de
la crise économique et sociale
exclusivement où ça vient aussi parce
que déjà avant cette crise il y avait un
problème on sait qu' il ya un problème
de corruption en grèce est ce que cette
ce problème et j'arrive dire
conjoncturelle ou est-ce qu'il est
structurel le problème que nous
rencontrons dans ce reportage est
extrêmement lié à la crise économique et
financière de la grèce
et comme on dit représenter le système
grec comme un autre système comme étant
un système parfait et qui a basculé dans
les grandes difficultés qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui ce serait une erreur
évidemment mais je pense que notre
objectif n'est pas de refaire l'histoire
du système de santé publique grecque
par contre ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui est
clairement conjoncturel est clairement
lié à des coupes budgétaires très
significatif très dur sur le système de
santé l'un des médecins disaient on est
au fond du trou
ça peut pas être pire est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça ou est ce que
quand c'est que malheureusement ça peut
encore être pire et je vais j'espère
qu'il a raison évidemment donc par
contre je ne crois pas à la mécanique du
du fond qui fait que ont rebondi on peut
toujours descendre plus loin je pense
qu'effectivement si on continue à avoir
un système qui est attaquée avec des
coupes budgétaires comme celle-là
immanquablement ce seront les
généralistes qui ne pourront plus donner
de soi dans une couverture universelle
et le problème de la santé un peu comme
le logement mais certainement dans la
santé c'est plus clair c'est une
couverture universelle qui est
absolument nécessaire parce que dès
qu'on commence à exclure des populations
dès qu'on commence à demander un système
assurantiel où les gens doivent fait la
démarche de se couvrir au bout du compte
toutes les politiques de santé publique
ne sont plus réalisable parce que des
gens sont dedans et des gens sont en
dehors
alors est ce qu'il y à un phénomène un
peu général on vient de voir l'exemple
grec mais est ce que dans toute cette
europe qui est profondément touchée sur
le plan social par la crise est-ce que
les aspects sanitaires sont importants
ailleurs vous le voyez j'imagine vous
avez des des dispensaires un petit peu
partout en europe en espagne au portugal
par exemple tout à fait donc on voit et
au portugal en espagne en grèce en
france en belgique en hollande en
angleterre dans les dispensaires que
nous avons ouvert on voit le même type 2
de tendance est à dire on commence à
toucher au coeur des populations et plus
à tous ceux qui étaient en périphérie
qui n'avait déjà pas accès au système
aujourd'hui c'est les gens qui avaient
accès au système qui n'ont plus accès à
ce système de sion même par exemple en
france ou en belgique
mais en france on va voir par exemple
une augmentation assez significative et
en belgique également du nombre de
personnes mal logées dans le nombre de
personnes sans abri ou simplement mal
logés et donc on va voir que pendant des
périodes hivernales des maladies vont ce
chrono 6 et dans une population qui
jusqu'ici était quand même relativement
bien prise en charge parce que les
systèmes de santé hospitaliers donc
deuxième niveau ou de premier niveau des
généralistes avaient la possibilité
avait les marges pour les prendre en
charge aujourd'hui elle on allait mal et
donc et donc ces personnes se retrouvent
avec un suivi médical qui est largement
fragilisée oui est ce que vous diriez
peut-être pour conclure que médecins du
monde et d'autres ong sont en train
malgré elle de remplacer les états qui
sont défaillants non vraiment ce n'est
pas du tout l'objectif de médecins du
monde remplacera objectif vous faites ce
n'est pas ce qu'on fait ce que notre de
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui est de
montrer à travers des exemples
extrêmement concret mais sur des
tranches de population parce que nous ne
savons pas où offrir une couverture
universelle c'est de montrer les les
implications des choix qui sont faits
nous ne sommes ne seront ne pouvons pas
en en ayant trois quatre vingt trente
quarante centres remplacer les milliers
de centres de santé qui font un travail
extraordinaire au quotidien merci
beaucoup
pierre vermeren d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans europe hebdo c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires
oh
non